si je vous disais que la chute du mur de
berlin et du un papier lui par hasard
lors d'une conférence de presse ou aux
nombres insuffisante d'armes dans les
stocks pour repousser quelques milliers
de personnes
[Musique]
le 9 novembre 1989 le monde entier
assiste à la chute d'une frontière que
l'on pensait encore solidement en place
pour au moins quelques décennies je ne
penserai pas voir la chute du mur de
berlin de mot vivre pensé que mes
enfants peut-être le veirem ben moi je
ne croyais pas c'était tellement solide
les régimes été tellement dur que
c'était inimaginable
symbole d'une allemagne coupé en deux
depuis 1949 par la guerre froide mais
aussi celui d'un monde partagé entre
deux blocs qui se font face
retour sur la chute de ce qu a appelé
l'occident et les allemands pendant près
de 30 ans le mur de la honte
[Musique]
la chute du mur de berlin et certains
événements inattendus mais pas
inexplicable et pour comprendre il faut
repartir du point de départ c'est à dire
l'arrivée de mikhaïl gorbatchev à la
tête de l'urss en 1985
symbole d'une jeune garde voulant
s'opposer à la vieille nomenclatura pour
tenter d'inaugurer une sorte de
communisme moderne et cette opposition
va éclater au grand jour à berlin lors
du lancement des célébrations des 40 ans
de la république démocratique allemande
le 6 octobre 1989 avec tout le monde qui
vient là tout le gotha du communiste
fidel castro va tout le monde est là et
puis donc il ya des parades avec déjà
des gens qui crient gorbatchev
gorbatchev sous-entendu on veut des
réformes
et puis pendant le dîner de gala c'est
dans un nouveau lieu qui s'appelle le
palais de la république sous les
fenêtres et à des milliers de gens qui
viennent et qui au lieu d'applaudir à
tous et ses grandes figures réclament
des réformes et réclame gorbatchev
gorbatchev et ça se termine très mal
parce que les la police qui au départ
avaient des consignes en disant c'est la
fête quand même pas là comme c'est
tellement déroulant il commença à
refouler les gens dans le quartier à
côté et il les enferme et ils matraquent
il ya plus de 3000 arrestations ce pas
exactement deux à trois mille
arrestations à travers tout le pays car
il n'y a pas qu'à berlin qu'on conteste
lors de cette soirée michael gorbatchev
continue de plaider pour mettre en place
ces réformes
symbolisée par cette phrase à enrico
necker alors dirigeant de la rda
l'histoire punit celui qui est en retard
[Musique]
les arrestations déclenché une vague de
protestations et chaque soirée apporte
son lot de preuve que la peur a changé
de camp
notamment lorsque les agents de la stasi
qui surveillent les allées et venues des
manifestants se font copieusement
insultés par ces derniers sans réagir
à la mi octobre 89 donc trois semaines
avant la chute du mur il ya une
révolution de palais ouvir la vieille
garde
il ya le doux fort du
du chef de l'allemagne de l'est richard
dicker qu'il prend sa place s'appelle
egon krenz et trance il se dit bon il
faut que je voulais vendre pour que ça
ou qui se passe des choses
il commence une première réforme des
voyages parce qu'ils savent que c'est
car au delà des réformes c'est la
liberté de voyager que réclament les
manifestants mais également la volonté
de voir un pays coupé en deux depuis
presque 40 ans se réunifier et arrive
enfin le fameux soir du 9 novembre 1989
il ya un papier qui étiez préparé pour
donner la liberté de voyage total aux
gens sans autorisation préalable qu'elle
est une révolution est donc la journée
se passe le 9e rang de ce papier est
élaboré le soir le porte parole qui est
lui-même membre du bureau politique doit
faire une conférence de presse comme il
fait tous les soirs et günter schabowski
au moment où il va à la conférence de
presse qui voit krenz donc le nouveau
chef du parti qui abattront donc du pays
et lui dit ah tiens j'ai un pape il a
sur les voyages faut que tu de leur
donne sarah la presse et l'autre prend
la chemise c'est parce qu adobe monte
dans la voiture il va au centre de
presse il s'installe sur de presse qui
fut répondre à des questions purement il
ya un journaliste italien qui lui dit
mais vous aviez tenté une réforme des
voyages l'autre jour là qui a été un
flop complet
quelles leçons vous en tirez hélas
schabowski dit elle pense à mais j'ai le
sait le papier que l'autre m'a donné
donc ils sont le papier dit j'ai un truc
à vous dire là dessus et il lit le
papier en disant à partir de là bas
voilà désormais les citoyens
est-allemands vont pouvoir sortir sans
autorisation préalable et c est alors qu
un jeu réaliste ouest allemand cette
fois ci qu'il dit mais c'est quand ce
sera quand cette histoire je pars du
principe que c'est immédiat et donc
c'est une bombe atomique qui va exploser
parce que tout d'un coup à la liberté de
voyage donc ipso facto le mur ne sert
plus à rien et là les abonnés sont
méfiants mais à huit heures du soir
la première chaîne ouest allemand il
regarde plus la télé reste à nantes la
seule qu'il croit le télé c'est une
telle propagande est la première chaîne
ouvre en disant décision révolutionnaire
désormais les alouettes vont pouvoir
voyager librement et alors les gens qui
ont vu cette c'était ce journal ont
commencé à aller dans un poste de
bataille le principe de frontières entre
berlin est et berlin ouest qui s'appelle
mort dans le jeu proche mais avant ça il
ya quelques centaines de pékin qui
viennent vers 9 heures débat je veux
sortir le colonel qui dirige le post tu
meurs j'ai pas de consignes personne
sort ici mais c'est aussi officielle sur
le passé à la télévision
non moi j'ai pas trop sinon qu'ils les
envoient un commissariat gérard vial
commissariat n'en sais rien kim et
pendant ce temps là les gens
s'accumulent 2010 plusieurs dizaines de
milliers et ils appellent à la stasi il
appelle le ciel j'ai déjà des milliers
de gens qui demandent à sortir qu'est ce
que je fais et personne ne lui donne
conseiller puis à un moment il ya un
team qui l'écoutent débrouille toi fais
ce que tu veux et donc lui renier ses
officiers généraux officiers avec lui
dire combien on a combien de temps un
peu interloqués
il chiffre à 15 donc avec 15 armes même
si on tire bien on va descendre combien
100 personnes et puis après on sera tous
pendus donc à prendre on ouvre il envoie
un message aux 6es de la stasi en disant
j'ouvre la barrière à 23h29 la barrière
s'ouvre soumis à un flot humain qui va
se déverser sur berlin ouest à la
personne a prévu ça mais vous avez des
milliers de gens qui pendant la nuit
pour être toute la nuit dans les rues de
berlin ouest
voilà comme ça et après c'est fini il ya
plus de mieux vous avez ouvert la chose
comme il n'existe plus
[Musique]